Guys, the final final announcement on my stream addressing my
assault allegations and my stalking allegations is I got
I just want to kick off the Deadpool for my my wife to be in
style. Okay, how long until this woman no longer exists on this
earth? Guys, bets start now.
Now, I think we're going to do the tectone video. We might do
the WestJet Misk video as well. So, it turns out one trip to
a psychiatrist, guys. Spoiler alert, he's not schizophrenic.
Who knew that's going to come out in the video we're going to
watch in his return stream, okay? But he's not schizophrenic.
But you'll notice when he said under oath that he got diagnosed
at a university, it was like in an informal way almost that like
would be really hard to probably find records on.
Right. And then when they asked, "Have you ever gotten any other
treatment? Have you ever gotten any other help from a mental
professional?" No. Nothing that could produce a record.
Right. All right. Without further ado, let's get to his actual
stream. >> I'm going to say this very specifically. I'm
going to say this very specifically. Okay. And so we're all going
to listen up.
I believe that if you're here until the end of the stream, you're
going to feel very satisfied.
Okay? Just like your mom. You're going to feel very
And I want to speak very specific. I'm going to address every
false allegation that I can. So every false allegation that I
can talk about, I'm going to here. So hopefully everything makes
sense. Okay. Hopefully everything makes sense. Uh man. Okay.
Right there.
He's going to address every false allegation
I can talk about. Well, the ones he can talk about apparently.
I don't even know what those false allegations are.
But are those the ones anybody cares about? Are those the allegations
anyone gives a about?
Right. I don't know who cares about any of the allegations that
he's not literally like not supposed to talk about. Is there
one? It was falsely alleged that he is schizophrenic. Well, falsely
alleged by him.
So, I don't know if we're I don't know what we're even going
to talk about here.
I'm guessing it'll be every single nitpick from the Miskf streams.
So, if Msk said something like Tech was charged, which I think
he said in the first stream, he'll try to go to that.
I'm just so beyond that, right? taking the most superficial
dumb criticisms or dumb points made that are totally superficial.
They're not substantive in any way, right?
And trying to make those the thing people are actually mad about
is totally fake. Okay, that's not what people are upset about
at all. People aren't upset that you're like um or sorry, people
aren't mad. There aren't a lot of people saying you're going
to prison. As much as you say that, there aren't a lot of people
who think you're actually going to jail.
I've heard now Tactical Templar said it. Legal Mindset said it.
I The WestJet guy, I think, said it. And now Tee saying it. There
are so many people who say, "I'm going to jail." Who Who says
you're going to jail? Who legitimately says Who
is there a single person who's looked into this at all that you
think has any kind of informed opinion whatsoever? not even like
um super informed, just like that they've looked at the content
and they think you're going to prison.
>> I think you guys will be very satisfied with today's
stream. Uh and hopefully I'm not going to leak anything. I'm
kind of feeling like a boomer right now. My mod made me something
>> that uh they want me to react to today. So, we're we're
going to do that. Uh
>> He says, "My mods made this for me,
right? my mods made this for me and there things I have to address
for them to keep working for me. Like as if his mods were like
upset about the
the assault case, right? The assault protective order and they
wanted their their concerns assuaged, but it's not. It's just
a bunch of jokes.
It's a bunch of It's a PowerPoint with a bunch of jokes, I guess.
>> Awesome. This is great. Okay. And then All right. Cool.
Cool. Cool. Cool. Sorry, that's that's spoilers for later. That's
spoilers for later. Okay, that should be great.
I made a uh I I made a PowerPoint. Oh, sorry. Okay, let me rephrase
that. My mods made me a PowerPoint where they said I have to
address these if they're going to continue working for me. So,
I I you know, listen, I'm too stupid to do this by myself. So,
I kind of got to I got a I got a team that works with me. You
understand? Yeah. I have to pull out the whiteboard. [laughter]
Okay. Okay. question. >> Uh, he literally pulls out the
white. I don't know. Okay. >> Honest honest question for
>> I guess you you got to do like the the laughing through
it, right? You have to do the laughing through it. You have to
do the joking through it or else
you just don't get to move forward. >> Anybody Okay, hear
me hear me the out, guys. For anybody who's ever been in a relationship,
have you ever not had communication issues where visual aid helps?
Like, am I am I crazy here? Like, I I don't know. I feel like
it's not even that I feel like that's not even crazy. Am I Am
I crazy? I don't know. I mean, I'm I'm being told that that's
the worst thing in human history. I I don't know. I mean,
[__] it is what it is. Unmedicated Skitso. Oh, man.
Oh,
the whiteboard is a reference to Lucari.
What? The whiteboard's not a reference Oh, hold on. The
Wait, what are you talking about? The whiteboard is a reference
to the actual Jesus Christ.
The whiteboard is a reference to the whiteboard he pulled up
for a conversation with his girlfriend about consent and what
it means.
That's the reference. Come on, man. >> Hey, can you follow
along? [laughter]
>> Uh yeah.
Hey, let's do let's do a poll here, guys.
Hey, [clears throat] type one if you think I did it. Type two
if you think I'm an innocent man.
It's like OJ Simpson coded. He's He's releasing his book. Did
I do it? >> Let's see.
>> Definitely three. >> Definitely three. Three.
Three. Three. Three. Three. Three. Three.
>> What a what a crazy barrier to entry.
You know what I'm saying? Let me let me pause this. We're going
to do we're going to pull out the white. >> We got some
threes. We got some threes in the chat. >> Anyways, yeah.
Let's uh let's talk about this. The bear to entry protect. All
right. What do we got? What was our first controversy? So, first
one, I was a cheater at Ark Knights because YOU'RE A FILTHY AMERICAN.
YOU CAN'T BE GOOD AT our Ark Knight game. You cheater. Okay,
great. I was too good at Arc Knights. I was too good at Arc Knight,
so they call me a cheater, bro. You're [__] white
in 2026.
GET the out of here, man. Get the
>> [__] out of here. >> I don't because
I'm
ugly white. You're white. Disgusting. Uh, white.
White. You're white in 2026.
GET the out of here, man.
Nobody,
by the way, nobody ever thinks
Nobody's ever thought this. Nobody, bro. Oh, sorry. Nobody of
consequence.
Like the It's just so stupid. I
uh I shouldn't say nobody's ever thought it cuz obviously people
do think it, but it's like it doesn't affect you. Like it's not
real. It's not real. It's only real if you go to the same extent
that like a bunch of woke people do about other kinds of racism,
then you could say it's real, right? Otherwise, it's like at
the margins. It doesn't affect your life in any way. It's never
actually held you down in some way, right? Like it can feel if
somebody tells you you're white, I don't care about your opinion
because that's like racist, right? That's racist.
But I man, I super don't [__] I'm like somebody who's
like okay with some of the identity stuff and I just find the
crying about it cringe, man. Like I'm I'm okay if you like
if you want to argue that white people should be able to organize
is like a voting block or something. I'm okay with that. I I
don't you could you could say that. You could talk about that.
Some people think that's racist. I don't think that's a problem.
You know, organizes an interest group. But then doing the thing
where it's like, oh, everybody everybody's racist to me and it
it really me. No. Come on. Come on, man. >> Get the out
of here. Holy [__] You better be Asian to play my
video games. So, they call me a cheater. Disgusting. They didn't
know I'm 22% black.
All right. What was next? [snorts]
Uh, from there. Ah, what what was the next one? I Oh, yeah. And
then I was a snitch. This was actually before the first thing
was I was a snitch. There was that guild in Skylanders Ring of
Heroes that was cheating and I told the devs and then they got
the devs banned. So, okay. So, first of all, I'm a cheater. I'm
a snitch. Elephant in the room. Elephant in the room. >> White
gh Oh my god. Oh my god, bro. White people have it so hard it's
ridiculous. Uh, I'm not even going to lie. Like, dude, white
people have it so hard it's nuts. Oh, dreamy drama. That's true.
That's true. And then there was the dreamy drama. Ooh, there
it is. Manipulator.
Yep. I remember. I remember there was Dreamy and they said, "Oh
my god, and in our DMs, oh my god, he's he's gaslighting me in
our DMs. He's gaslighting me." Oh, dude.
A lot of people seem to think the same kinds of things about
this guy. Turns out anyone who's close to this guy ends up thinking
something very similar about him. Isn't that strange?
Isn't that weird that all of the people who know this guy for
any period of time eventually are like, "Oh, this guy's like
a total piece of I don't want to talk to I don't want to be around
this guy. This guy, >> dude, he was he was berating me
in our DMs. He all it blackmailed me in our DMs." And then well,
we all saw the DMs and then we all saw I was like, "Hey, man."
Uh or woman, I don't know what the [__] they are
to be honest. In 2026, I mean, [snorts] after the Orchid and
the Genchin, there was HSR. That was the first time I was called
a
Yep. That's number one because
of our girl Robin, man. Man. Yep. Yep. People were telling me
I assaulted Robin. You remember that? You remember that? She
She Yep. Yep. Yep. All right. And then we got uh what was the
next one? Oh, there was another one. Oh, I have a dad.
Oh, man. That's unlucky.
Like
does anybody else just find this I I don't know. It's bad enough
when you get one instance of it, but back to back to back to
back to back, he just totally like lies about what anybody's
like annoyed about with him, like the actual wrong things he
did in any of these cases,
right?
His summation of the discovery of people that his dad had, you
know, was a prolific assaulter, harasser in the military. His
his response to this is I have a dad. People found out I have
a dad and they try to cancel me for it.
No, they found out that your dad had done a bunch of sexual assault
and it was funny for one thing, but you lied a bunch around it
and you self victimized a bunch around it in the most embarrassing
of ways. You cried about your childhood sexual assault, right?
Your childhood
and blamed it on Hassan bringing up your dad, right? You cried
about this on
What else did you do? Oh, you clearly lied about whether or not
you knew about it. You told people you didn't know about it and
then people found clips for you like two or three months previous.
Literally being told about it in your chat and you saying that
person is like doesn't know what they're talking about.
Like come on, man. >> That one that one's unlucky, bro.
That's a man. I got some [__] for that one, >> Like
some people have shame. They couldn't do this. They couldn't
lie about the things they're being accused of to this extent.
But Teone has no >> because you know he he passed me down
his genetics.
I was his spiritual successor. It's like all for one. He had
to pass that [__] down. You know, I had to eat some
of his hair. And thank I don't know what my son's going to do
cuz I don't got any. But yeah, man. Oh, having a dad in 2026,
that's rough. Uh and then what else we got? We got Grifter.
Yeah, we got Grifter.
Yep.
Yep. And the biggest one, the big R word.
I'm a uh Anyways, uh let's get
>> Grifter, which you basically said the reason you did
this because you're accused of sexual assault.
So that's why you pivoted. That's that's literally what the Grifter
thing is about. It's >> into it, huh?
>> Um let's let's get serious for for a while. Um guys,
I took uh I took I took five months off.
I did. Um, now admittedly it was supposed to be 2 months off.
Where are you guys ready for story time? Are you Are you guys
ready for this? Uh, we >> Oh, is he going to lie to us
about why he took all this time off? Why he retired on the day
the protective order got extended? Is he going to lie to us about
it?
Cuz basically,
here's why he took time off. Because for months and months and
months, he couldn't stop seething about this woman. Then she
filed a protective order. After she filed the protective order,
he continued to see about her, right? And realized that if he
streamed after that protective order was originally filed, he
wouldn't be able to control himself. So, he took time off his
streaming, right?
And it was supposed to be two months. I'm guessing that lines
up pretty closely with in November
when
I I'm guessing that lines up with So, two months is when no in
November. That's when they were supposed to have the next hearing,
I think, for the protective order.
I believe so. And then I believe Tekton's own lawyers said, "Wait,
let's not have the the hearing." Now, I can't remember precisely
which extension this was, but for one of them, Te's own lawyers
said, "Wait, can we push this hearing back? We want to collect
more evidence." What evidence they collected? I have no idea.
Okay. I really don't know.
I I actually don't know. If he's going to try to say that he
was just on some spiritual journey and that's why he was taking
time off, he is just lying. I don't know. It's very obvious from
the timeline that he is just lying. We've put that timeline out.
We've explained it on stream. It's very obvious. Okay, >> we
got we got a lot to talk about. Yeah, I got to tell you guys
what's going on, why everything happened, and uh we're going
to get through everything, and then we got a PowerPoint to go
through, and then I'm even going to do a Q&A after. Yep.
Uh I'm gonna do a Q&A after. Uh, first of all, if you have
a second, if you do have a second, um, if you could like the
video, if you could subscribe to the channel, if you could turn
the bell on for notifications, I would greatly appreciate that.
So, if you can just take a second, I would, uh, I would greatly
appreciate that. Okay. Um, if you're coming here to watch me
cry, it's not going to happen. Uh, I'm a man. Cry this stream.
So, if you're coming here to watch me cry, it's not going to
happen. Uh, I'm a man. I WAS GOING TO SAY,
MAN, I wish I hadn't seen any clips cuz I I did see the clip
on this one, which is probably why I paused. I think I would
have paused even if I hadn't seen the clip. Bro, you cry a lot.
Bro, you cry a lot about stuff. >> Like the fact that Hassan
wants to imply that I'm a monster. >> YOU KNOW THAT, HASSAN
PER >> BASED off of who my father is is disgusting. like
this man has I guess epigenetic memories of it's just like it's
a familial obligation over here >> and to imply that I'm
a >> yeah whatever he made a joke >> dude
h
>> oh dude wow listen guys if you want to >> oh wrong
one wrong one wrong link here we're back to here he's a man he
would never cry I'm a man I would never cry by the way
I don't even have a problem with him crying I now am fully on
board with that crying being totally performative, a total act.
But I wouldn't have a problem with a man crying. I don't have
a problem with that. Right? What was embarrassing about that
was that he was trying to like farm sympathy from Hassan
when Hassan was just talking.
Right? Basically, Hassan was talking trying to make him feel
bad and then he went live and was like started crying and going,
"Hassan totally owned me." It's embarrassing. >> Men don't
cry. We don't do that anymore. Okay. Well, I was a weak little
boy back in the day. No longer are those days. What happened
was, in case you guys don't remember, um, a long time ago, I
used to be a professional wrestler and my dad told me that I
was too much of a to do this and I needed to get, you know, juiced
up. So, he used to rub Okay, that sounds weird. Uh, he used to
put uh testosterone cream on me because I thought testosterone
cream and testosterone injections would just give you extra testosterone.
Um, it does do that, but the problem is that whenever you inject
testosterone,
um, it cuts off your natural flow of testosterone. Um, and I've
been doing TRT on and off for a very long time. Uh, but now,
uh, since I've gone on break, I am completely off
>> I I mean, here's the weird thing. I straight up don't
believe him. I don't believe that he's off of TRT.
I don't believe him.
I I straight up don't. I like absolutely
Right.
TRT with no muscle definition. Sus. I actually like don't believe
that he's off of TRT. I don't believe like any of that essentially.
He just I feel like he says things on stream and he doesn't care
if they correspond to reality at all. He like just builds his
own like narrative for himself. And he would say anything to
his stream. It doesn't matter what the reality is.
It doesn't matter, man. >> I'm 100% off it. And my testosterone
levels are fluctuating now between 400 and 600 naturally. And
I no longer require that because it just I took a long enough
break and I you know I've watched enough of those videos where
it's like you need to eat three steaks a day and eat eggs to
get your natural testosterone back up. Regardless um I had to
get my natural testosterone back up. I am now completely legitimate.
Uh which feels great. Uh I no longer require um >> this
is basically the case. This is where I'm at. Shack it up is I
do believe he is just a pathological liar. Yes. that he is just
Tom Fer is the same kind of pathological liar. He's just far
more charismatic so he doesn't get pinned down in the same way,
but it's just consistently
Hey guys, it turns out that I took this break and all of the
things that you thought were wrong with me that I said were wrong
with me. Actually, none of those things are wrong with me. And
I'm actually I'm actually totally cured of all the things that
were bad. Out of nowhere, I'm cured of all the bad things, guys.
Right.
Oh my god. We're cured. We're cured. We're We're all the way
cured, guys.
>> A person to stick a needle in my ass every week. Which,
by the way, that sucks because I have no ass. Dude, my my act
is so flat, dude. I I fully believe, by the way, we called this
out during his videos. I fully believe that he didn't set this
room up himself. I I like I think this guy is so fake that he
either just got his girlfriend to do it entirely or he like hired
a decorating a decorator or he bought a furnished
It's like one of those three options. I thought it was a furnished
place. I'm not 100% sure, but it's so funny how he went from
like the anime room, right? The anime room. This is all manga
on the wall here. It's all manga. It's all anime, video games.
That's everything in this room to guys, I'm a conservative now.
I have a bald eagle.
I have a marble bus. We're like, we're basically Marcus Aurelius.
I have I hunt now. I hunt now. I have clocks. I have old antique
clocks. I respect old handcrafted things. Stacey, thank you for
the primer. Appreciate it,
dude. It's It's like unironically Tucker Carlson. Yes, it is
Tucker Carlson. It's the Tucker Carlson play, guys. Look, I was
a total like liberal. I was like some big city guy. I've never
I've never been outside in my life. Although with Tucker, I believe
he maybe fished and stuff, but regardless,
now I buy some dude's woodsy cabin and I'm going to go do this
whole LAR.
Like, off. I I forgot the part of meditations
where he talked about crying about how you were raped. Okay.
Because somebody called you a rap on the internet who had no
idea about this.
Actually,
actually, I CAN'T BELIEVE HASSAN brought this up. I can't believe
I can't believe Hassan brought this up. Marcus really is sitting
here like, "I can't believe Plato said this about me. I can't
believe I don't know if they lived at the same time."
[clears throat] >> Yeah. Yeah. I got the [__]
out of there. I had to get the [__] out of Austin.
There was way too many fans there. That [__] was
insane. BUT HOLY
DISAVOW. This guy's crazy.
Absolutely disavowed that commentary. What the [__]
What the tech tone? >> Austin is so gay, guys. I'm not
even going to lie. Holy is so gay. It's insane.
So, I got the out of there. Uh, and thank God, dude. People are
normal here, bro. Holy [__] People
>> they're normal here.
Get ready for this. will be he's going to tell you how they're
normal. It will be the most superficial measure of normality
you could possibly think of. It will be >> JUST TIPPED
$5. >> OH MY GOD. >> HE IS AND POLAR OPPOSITE. He
is build like a Spanish exam. >> That is too big for his
shoulders for his body. Sorry. Look how narrow his shoulders
are. He is built like a Spanish
exclamation mark.
Is that the upside down the interobang? Are you saying he's built
like an interobang? in
He's built like a Is that
Which one? A Spanish question mark. No, you didn't mean this.
What did you mean? What is a Spanish question mark? Spanish
question mark. What is a Spanish question mark? Oh, it's the
upside down one. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
I I'll be real. I did think that was like a I thought that was
an interero bang for some reason. The upside down I I'm okay.
Very cool. Very cool. Are you saying he is hourglass shaped?
Is that a way of saying he is hourglass shaped?
>> Pause, dog.
>> So, I got the out of there. Uh, and thank god, dude.
People are >> Oh, I almost played that again. I I went
back to like catch us back up and I almost play.
>> People are normal.
It's crazy. You want to know how you can tell if your town is
like normal? How can you tell if your hair colors are like black,
brown, and blonde and not
Wow. Wow. That's how you can tell they're normal, guys. A lack
of a lack of individualist expression is is to show how you're
It shows you're normal.
I I don't know if he realizes this. People in small towns can
can dress like
I I don't even know where to start with this person.
Bro, you have anime tattoos.
You have anime tattoos. You I guarantee you love every single
crazy looking anime character.
How can you tell these people are normal? Well, they they you
know, they don't have tattoos. They're not like tatted up freaks
here. They've got normal hair colors.
Okay. All right.
Do I have to pull up the defender registry and show how normal
the hair colors are for TechOne?
or lack of hair, possibly being bald. My >> like pink,
blue, green, neon, and nobody's wearing a fursuit. Oh my god.
>> Nobody's wearing a furs, dude. I
By the way, the small normal town he lives in, San Antonio, Texas.
Okay, that's the small normal town that Tekon has moved to. San
Antonio, Texas.
Correct me if I'm wrong. I think they're big enough to have a
NBA team.
>> Yeah, we move to San Antonio. Yeah, this town's [__]
great. Uh, really good. Really good people. Very good vibes.
Uh, I'm not going to say who I talk to because if I do, then
you're going to attack them. [laughter]
>> Uh, the people who I talk to the most. Okay, let me
tell you guys who my best friends are. My best friends are Ms.
Kef, Assan,
Denims, Mike from PA. I really like these guys. Um, they're they're
great. They're actually my biggest supporters. They're Oh my
god, they're friends are My best friends are Ms. Kefan. Talk
to the most. Okay, real. Let me tell you guys who my best friends
are. My best friends are Sorry, I didn't go back. Really good.
Yeah, this sounds great. Uh, really good. Really good people.
Very good vibes. Uh, I'm not going to say who I talk to because
if I do, then you're going to attack them. [laughter]
that was closer, right? [laughter]
>> The people who I talked to the >> Oh, you caught
the cadence. Thank you. I actually did the cadence perfectly
but at a way different tone because I can't sound like that guy.
Okay. >> Yes. Did you have a lawyer check them? Okay. We
got to talk about this whole five lawyer thing. Okay. I'm going
to hope that this is on here. If there's any other >> Oh,
totally totally irrelevant side quest. All right. >> Questions
that you got. >> This will this will mirror, by the way,
exactly what Tactical Templar did, right? Where when there are
serious concerns, it will be, oh, this is just getting silly.
This is just getting absurd already, right? laughed off, not
not talked about. When there are unserious concerns, when there
are side pieces, there are totally insubstantial minor gripes,
those will be focused in on. That is the strategy. That is what
we will watch. >> Guys, please save them for dude. Every
single time people tell me I had five lawyers, that is I had
one
>> All right, cool. Here we go. Uh here we go. Addressing
the allegations. Um I think this is 34 slides. What is on these
slides? I don't know. Uh, let's get into it. What is a civil
case? All right. So, elephant in the room. Elephant in the room.
All right. A lot. >> What is a civil case?
Okay. >> A lot of people want to act like they're lawyers
these days. Okay. They They do. What is a civil case? Spoiler
alert, guys. I lost a civil case. I did. I did. Hey. Hey. I did.
And we're going to talk I lost. It's true. It's true. And we're
going to talk about everything. Um, what is a civil case? So,
a civil case is essentially a vibe check to where they see Hm.
How are this guy's vibes? Uh,
Yeah. L for me. I'm
How are these guys vibe? How is this guy's vibes? I mean,
uh, how do I put it? That's not what they're checking, right?
They're not just saying, "What are this guy's vibes like in the
room?"
There's evidence presented,
but again, he's not like he is wrong.
How do I put it?
There was not a huge barrier to what they were looking to prove
to get a protective order granted, right? There was not a huge
like unfathomable,
you know, barrier to filing this and succeeding in it,
but he helped them succeed massively. So,
here we'll we'll uh we'll listen to that again. Let me listen
to that one more time. >> How are this guy's vibes? Uh,
Yeah. L for me. I'm
And I run my mouth way too much. One thing that I've learned
and >> Yeah. So, this is this is what they're kind of running
with is is he did way too much talking and that's the only reason
the
protective order was filed.
I do think it helped the protective order get extended for as
long as it was. I do think it helped the judge find him liable
for stalking, but the stalking stuff does not have to do with
the stuff. Sorry, not liable. That they found probable cause
to believe that he was stalking her, right? Probable cause to
believe he was committing the stalking like thing laid out in
the Texas penal code. And they also found it was reasonably,
you know, it was reasonably believable that he insulted
And that is disjoint from the stalking thing, the talking too
much thing. So, as much as the talking too much thing did get
him the stalking protective order, it was both a a stalking and
assault protective order, right? Could have had a protective
order for either
I do believe they found that there was reasonable you could reasonably
believe or you could reasonably suspect he assaulted her as well.
That is disjoint.
>> Throughout this slideshow, there's going to be uh consistent
change. I am going to start tweeting 95% less. I un >> It's
not just about tweets. It's about what you're tweeting, who you're
tweeting it at, what you're doing it in service of. Right? It's
not just that you yap too much. You do yap too much. That much
is obvious, right? But that is not what you are being given this
protective order for. It is not simply for yapping too much,
right? Yes, there are many times on streams where he is talking
about this. Okay.
Do I have to cut? Hold on. Let me cut over to some other stuff
here for you guys cuz
>> I got I got so much rage in my heart right now. It's
insane.
>> I don't think I've ever been this angry to where I can't
even think straight.
>> I've never had someone be so
pathetic that they're willing to lie to try to ruin my life cuz
they can't get over me. There's no way.
Just in case. Just in case you were like thinking, well, this
could be about like Frame and not Pink and like it could be about
somebody else and oh, you don't know. He's not saying name. Just
in case you were wondering if it was if he was like raging at
someone else. No, no, no. He wants to make it really clear for
you that he's super mad at Pink. He's very angry at Pink. That's
who he wants to go after. Okay. >> Someone is that pathetic.
I'm just so
>> It's
pathetic. These people just get more and more pathetic every
day. They can't go after me because I've never done bad [__]
So, they have to go after my family and they can't go after me
for the truth. So, they resort to listening to a deranged
and they're going to pass it off as the truth. It makes me want
to drive a nail through my skin.
By the way, when he says when he does the whole laughing thing
like I don't care. Oh, what? My my ops are lying about me. I
don't care. What he just laid out there is exactly why he does
care. Exactly how much it [__] with him. Exactly
how upset he gets about every one of these people who talk about
him on the internet about how much he can't handle it. So he
just lied in his most recent video where he like laughs. He's
like, "Oh, you telling me my ops are lying about me? Yeah. Said
this bad thing about you."
Yeah. It's totally fake bravado. This is when he's got his like
shields down. When he's not trying to perform for the stream,
this is how he really feels. Okay. It's literally if you go back
the these people are just more and more pathetic every day. They
can't go after me. I've never done a bad thing. >> They
can't go after me cuz I've never done bad [__] So
they have to go after my family. >> That's talking about
Denim's mic for PA Hassan talking about his dad being a prolific
military >> and they can't go after me for the truth. So
they resort to listening to a
liar. So, this would be him talking about Pink
and how he blames Pink for all of these people having the ability
to talk about him, right?
>> And they're going to pass it off as the truth. It makes
me want to drive a nail through my skin. It's been It's been
>> So, 10 months from here is Yes. This is again just confirming
the pink timeline. July of 2024. >> 10 months of this person
just never stopped lying. It's insane.
10 months. 10 months.
It's every day. A civil case isn't determined by proof. It's
determined by vibes. And usually the way that court cases work
for like criminal cases, you need to have proof to prove that
someone's guilty. But in a civil case, I needed proof to prove
that I'm innocent, which was hard. And I'm a bastard. Uh so
the court decided that I'm a vibrant. Uh yeah, and my vibes were
>> I mean if the court decided that they would be the last
to know that's pretty obvious to everybody else around you, but
unfortunately that's not a determination the court typically
makes. Tone. All right. It is very obvious to everybody that
you are a vibes 100%.
100%. Yeah. >> Terrible. So, the thing that I learned is
Teone, stop tweeting. Uh, because my vibes are terrible. And
I don't think I've ever been on Twitter and done something where
I was like, you know what? I'm going to tweet something that's
positively going to affect my life. But yeah, the vibes are off.
The vibes are >> All right, so I lost the vibe check. It's
true. Uh, next up, >> are you going to jail? >> Bad
vibes, dude. It's just bad vi bad vibes, man. That's it. >> Oh
my god. Oh, [sighs] >> nobody says this. Nobody said this.
Nobody thinks this.
This is crazy. Anybody who's criticizing you, not Shimu, not
Nobody said you're going to jail. I think the closest this got
was Shimu saying that he thought it seemed pretty evident you
violated your your what do you call your protective order. Uh
that's it seemed like he retracted that. But you know, nobody
thought you were going to jail for sexual assault. They thought
if anything if anybody thought you might have some problems,
it was because of a violation of the protective order. That would
be >> What is that photo even? Um, I have seen obviously
so many people on Twitter tell me and inform me that I'm going
to jail. >> Yep. Dude, I I have seen people on Twitter
say with complete certainty that I'm in fact actually already
in jail. Yes, there are people who literally think that I'm going
to jail. I want to make this very clear, okay? And I'm going
to say this one time and I'm going to move on, guys. There was
already an eightmon
8month police investigation on >> They found nothing. The
case was suspended. I have no criminal charges. I was not convicted
of any crime because I didn't [snorts] >> What? What the
[__] did this just say? There's an 8-month criminal
investigation and police investigation on me. They found nothing.
The case was suspended. I have no criminal charges. Um, I don't
You don't know what they found on you? The case was suspended.
You can't say the case was suspended. They found nothing on me.
The case wouldn't be suspended if they found nothing on you.
You know what it would be if they found nothing on you, Techone?
The case would be
Can you hear me tapping on my I'm doing a drum roll on my keyboard
or on my desk. It would be closed. If they found nothing on you,
if they were like, "Oh, we looked into it. We found nothing.
We can't possibly do anything here." They would just close the
case. They wouldn't suspend the case. They would close the case.
right now. It might be that they had hang-ups, so they they didn't
even look for for certain things. It sounded like they wanted
Pink to do a phone call. I don't even know if this is possible
now. It sounded like they wanted Pink to do a phone call. She
decided not to do that, right? But it's suspended right now because
yes, she wanted basically to drop this. I think she had decided,
hey, I'm going to What I suspect happened was she suspended the
case and then Teone didn't stop talking about her and then she
went, "I need to file a protective order, right?
I was not convicted of any crime because I didn't do anything.
So, no, I'm not going to jail. >> You weren't convicted
of a crime because the criminal case about these allegations
was suspended. It doesn't mean that you didn't do anything. We
don't know that you didn't do anything. That is not proven out
by anything that's happened so far. Now, I will say in Tek's
defense slightly, it also doesn't mean he's guilty of this. I
tend to lean in that direction, but I would never say I think
we should jail tectone because he's obviously arrested, right?
No, that would be like a miscarriage of justice. You do need
to prove things out and that's not how the justice system works
in the entire western world. Right.
So, I don't think Tone should be jailed for being oralter
because I do not believe we've seen anything that proves to the
standard of reasonable doubt that he has raped somebody or assaulted
somebody. Right? There's not there's not the information available
publicly.
So that works in his favor. But when he goes in the opposite
direction and says, "Well, I'm I've been exonerated." No, you
haven't. You have not been exonerated.
>> No whammy. No whammies. No whammy. We're not going to
jail. We're not going to jail. I'm not in jail. I'm not a criminal
cuz I didn't do anything. They let you stream from jail. Well,
okay. Well, if I do go to jail, expect some collabs with Jeffrey
Epstein and PD. Uh yeah, which apparently I've also I'm way worse
than them. All right. Uh >> literally nobody's saying that.
You're just victimizing yourself. >> Great. Not yet. At
least don't jinx it. I know. I know. I know. I know. Kaisen gave
me a great stream idea. >> Nobody said that. >> We'll
do we'll do we'll do the jail >> Victimizing himself over
and over again. >> Am I going to jail? No. I'm not a criminal.
I didn't get convicted of anything. There was no evidence or
proof of me doing anything cuz I didn't do anything, guys. Okay.
My vibes are just terrible. I was horrifically underpaid. Anyways,
no, I'm not going to jail. All right. Where are your guns now?
This
I'm not going to lie. This this
some bro can WE TALK ABOUT THAT? THESE THEY TOOK my guns. What
can I Dude, I believe in America where we have the second amendment.
Okay, this wasn't a violation of your Second Amendment rights.
Um, in fact, speaking of the Second Amendment, I would love to
know exactly what Tet disclosed when buying his firearms. What
did Team disclose about his mental illness? What did he disclose
about his diagnosed schizophrenia? He talked about his hallucinations
constantly. What did he Because he only just got a diagnosis
counter to that. Right before that, he was diagnosed with
What happened there? How did he buy his guns in the first place
given that diagnosis? Right? Was he transparent about that diagnosis
when he got his guns? Do we have a Hunter Biden situation on
our hands? It'll be interesting to know.
Could have just got the Yeah, he could have used the gunshoo
100%.
But I'm I'm curious. I'm very curious. >> They took my
damn guns. >> Oh, [__] They took my damn guns.
They took my guns. Sorry, we're on. They took my guns.
Where is this? Where is this?
>> I'm not criminal. >> [__]
The second amendment.
>> My damn gun. Mango ain't got nothing to >> Now,
also, not only that, not only did he actually disclose his mental
illness on his registration forms, maybe he can't be caught.
I almost wonder if that's another thing that pushed him to go
and get the rediagnosis. Okay.
But
on top of that, it has been nearly unanimously 8 to1 decided
by the conservative Supreme Court in the year of our Lord 2024.
Raheem v. Who is Raheem v. United States? United States v. Raheem
that you are allowed to take somebody's guns if they have an
active civil restraining order relating to domestic abuse. You're
allowed to do that if they're a stalker, if they are abusing,
if they are physically abusing. You're allowed to take their
guns if there is an active restraining order against them. Been
decided. It is categorically constitutional to take your guns
away. >> Uh but to me, I don't really care. Um people were
telling me that I have like this huge gun collection. Um skits
can still buy guns. So is there no red flag there, Barry Q, that
says, "Hey, you have schizophrenia
and you need to show me like some evidence that you have this
under control. like I need a a note from your doctor. There wouldn't
be anything like that. Maybe not. It is the United >> I
had like four. I had and two of them didn't even do anything.
I had a Vector and a MP5K and I bought them cuz they looked cool
cuz they were from PUBG. And then I had a home defense shotgun
and a uh a handgun. H they're gone. No guns. Feels bad. Can I
still Wait, guys. Can I still play Fortnite?
Do we have any lawyers in chat? Can I Can I still play Fortnite
or no? I don't know. Like, is that allowed? No. No guns. Okay.
All right. We We'll do we'll do Melee only
>> Fortnite and PUBG. Okay, >> guys. Am I allowed
to keep my my game skins? They're guns, right? >> Yeah,
we we'll be talking about Frog Bandaids. All right. No more Fortnite.
>> None of that. All right, cool. Let's go to the next
one. Oh, I can't play Kafka either. OH MY GOD. OKAY. WELL, ALL
RIGHT. No guns. No guns on stream. Not >> only 5150. All
right. >> How does this impact you, guys? Guys, guys, I
I cannot go to jail. Did you know that there's no gun?
Just meme through jail, buddy. Oh my god. >> Just keep
me. Keep on memeing, dog. >> Oh my god.
>> Well,
now that my life is uh all out there, you know, that's great.
Well, let me rephrase that. Now that my lack of
>> I knew all of this. We knew all of this before the case,
right? This wasn't like this isn't new.
All of this stuff was out there. We all knew this. I mean, I
guess it's hitting the mainstream for the first time,
right?
But it's funny like he's talked about all of this. He's acting
like these are revelations. They aren't revelations to him. He's
shared them with his audience or they've been shared with his
audience in some way. >> Life is out there. Uh yes. Yes,
that is true. Now, okay, I am a very straight man. [snorts] I
am a very straight man. Uh but yes, I did find a little bit icky.
Can we be honest that are weird looking until they >> a
little bit icky brother? I don't I thought the I thought it was
the case that he didn't have sex with his wife like at all in
their relationship.
Like there's a difference between having a wife like a committed
partner for years,
right, and never having intercourse with them. That's beyond
icky, dude. That's way beyond icky. Trust me, there are a lot
of straight dudes who think are icky and as soon as they're like
a little bit horny, that goes all the way out the window. It's
just weird coming from him. It's actually weird coming from him.
>> I don't know. I [clears throat] don't think I'm gay.
I'm probably not gay. I could be gay. I could run with that same
>> Made me go ill icky for a while. Um, now I've thought
about this and we're going to have to figure this out. For some
reason now, the internet must know,
do I have a or not? Uh, I thought about a couple options. Number
one, I was thinking about just posting a photo of my on Twitter.
Probably not the greatest idea.
No, that would pretty cate that would pretty categorically put
this to bed.
I No, that would be totally That would be 100% proof.
Just one turkey tom picture and you're you're back in the game,
Techone. Okay. >> Didn't seem like it worked. Worked really
well for Drake. Worked really well for Speed. Uh, for me, don't
think it'll work because I'm not full black. I'm only 22% black.
Um, then I also thought about
>> Wait, did he just say Wait, did he just No, there's
no way he just said that. Guys, I can't post a picture because
realistically it's like on the line and you guys aren't going
to believe me. So,
he's like, if I post a picture, that wouldn't be conclusive evidence.
Actually, I would love to I would love to just go post a picture
to Twitter, but there would be a debate and I'm not sure I'm
not positive I'm going to win that debate. So, >> shoving
my This was real. I thought about getting hard on stream, turning
around, shoving my in a peanut butter can or a jar and then showing
you guys how deep the hole is. Um, but I feel like that's also
just a little bit
I I could I could CALL LIKE WHAT WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO DO? LIKE
MAKE A MOLD. Uh because you can because you
call Shina. I don't think Sha
wait. Yeah. Call one of your former partners and just get them
to testify. That's not your current girlfriend. >> She
might I I don't think the part is so small it's hard to say.
call doc. >> I will say probably the best I would say the
best evidence you have that he might have a micro is that despite
a lot of fame I don't know how much he just like hits on girls
and tries to have sex relationships with girls right I don't
know if he's like constantly hitting on girls he seems like the
kind of guy who makes like friendships first and then moves to
something with that being the case there might be a reason he
doesn't just go for like random hookups
>> all right next one ending a crime all right as so a
bunch of people on the internet have also told me for some reason
that I've nded someone because I don't want them to speak about
a crime.
>> Dude, doing the music too is just goofy as
uh yeah, you can't NDA criminal conduct, but you can NDA things
around criminal conduct. So technically like if you'd abuse somebody,
you couldn't make somebody sign an NDA not to disclose that abuse.
But what you could do is say I didn't do it. You know, I didn't
do it and I'll sue you if you say I did do it. And here's a document
that says I can sue you if you say I did do it. Right?
And that can make somebody fear. This is one of those things.
This is actually the chorus case over again, right? Where they
in their contract it definitely says that you have to funnel
things through them and then they go, "Well, we don't do that.
We don't make people do that." It's like, okay, but when you
put it when you put in the contract, that will make some people
obey the contract, even though you legally couldn't enforce it,
there will be people who just obey the contract without asking
a question. That's the problem, right? There are reasons you
can't do this, but if you do add this language to an NDA, people
will abide by it without questioning it, right? People will get
these things signed and then there's a whole court case to see
if you can actually enforce it. Now, with assault stuff, I don't
believe that's the case. But the funny thing is, and we could
check the transcript,
even though
he says this whole thing about NDAing a crime, he I believe he
admits to asking for
frame to be NDA so she can't accuse him again. I believe he admitted
to asking for this in the transcript. I'll look for it right
now. I'll back this up 5 seconds. I'll right now >> because
I don't want them to speak about a crime. Um, >> all right.
This is the part right here. So, the lawyer is trying to ask
TeeOne. Okay. So, and you also at the time of the lawsuit, you
wanted her to sign an NDA because you didn't want all of your
ex-wife's allegations public. Isn't that correct? So, I can't
tell if he wanted Frame or Pink to sign an NDA. I think it was
Frame. Okay. So, Tech was pushing like, "Hey, could you get her
to sign an NDA so she doesn't make these
now?" He says, "Can you repeat that?" So, we have to go down
a little bit. And then they ask about the lawyer. And you're
not originally, you weren't originally behind the lawsuit when
it started. But after you all broke up is when you withdrew your
support of the litigation. One more time. Sorry, trying to make
sure I understand. You're actually on my client's side. Blank's
side on that lawsuit up until you all broke up and you withdrew
your support of that lawsuit. Yes, I tried to support Pink with
whatever she needed. So people pointed to this is maybe him breaking
the NDA, his own NDA, right? But and in fact, here's the next
question. And in fact, what your concern was
what your what your concern was was not whether she should do
it or not. you were concerned more about the NDA language and
some violation of that that may possibly involve you. Correct.
I my intentions were to kind of just assist pink. I mean obviously
I think if I can toss myself a bone in those situations, I'll
do it. That is basically saying yes, I did. So people are thinking
um his concern was about being held liable for the breach of
the first NDA. I believe this is him saying no, no, no, no. What
I was telling Pink to do was to get my ex-wife Frame to sign
an NDA that says you can't bring up these allegations. So, he
was trying to do this even if he says he didn't couldn't, right?
He was trying to get Pink to push for that. And that's why he
answers, "If I think I can toss myself, obviously I think if
I can toss myself a bone in those situations, I'll do it." >> I'm
being told that I'm a grifter, right? because I'm I'm being told
that I said I'll do anything for content and when I lose a chunk
of my audience, I want to go find a new one. Oh, and I exaggerate
the things that I say.
Guys,
everybody does this.
Look, look, legit, everybody does this. When you're a content
creator and you want to be a content creator, when an audience
of yours dies, you're going to want to find a new audience. Cuz
if you don't, you end up like Mr. Pokey. When you're a content
creator and you alienate a section of your audience or you lose
a big section of your audience, if you only do one thing forever,
your channel's going to die. So yes, I started with Skylanders.
I go into Ark Knights. I go into Genchin. I go into Hawkeye.
I go into Weathering Waves. I go into General Commentary. I go
into Reacts. I go into politics. Absolutely. And do I say things
exaggerated that maybe I don't mean as much.
I'm a rage baiter.
I've always been a rage baiter. But yeah, you're you're godamn
right. If there's something that I can do to get some more views,
if there's some that I don't really care about that I know, >> guys,
I'm not a grifter. I'm just like I'm just like a businessman,
okay? I'm not a grifter. I'm just a businessman. >> Going
to make my channel better. You're goddamn right. I'm going to
talk about it because you know what? I like money.
>> full disclosure, I try not to take bad sponsors. But
that being said, stake.com hit me up. Cool. Yeah. No, that's
true. I I do cover different things. Uh I do try to evolve my
content when I do an audience. I do try to find a new one. know
why? Because I am a needy attention [__] and I need
this [__] It was so bad, bro. I would be in Discord,
>> okay? I mean, it's pretty transparent. I don't know
what >> I would be in Discord with my mods or like four
other random viewers of mine
and I would be like shout casting my TFT games like I was live
and it's like, bro, you're in a call with three people who are
muted. Who the are you talking to? And if any of my mods are
in chat, they can vouch. I was shout casting every TFT game I
do. I love this [__] I love being entertaining and
I like talking about the things people want me to talk about.
Uh but yeah, cool. Charlie Kirk's death greatly affected me.
It absolutely did. Um I don't know if I was still streaming when
this happened or not. I'm actually not sure. Um but Charlie Kirk
really me up. >> Uh I feel like it a lot of people. But
the reason why Charlie Kirk's death affected me so much was due
to the fact that Charlie Kirk got killed for speaking his mind.
>> Um and the things that Charlie Kirk was saying were
things that I say, were things that my grandparents say, were
things that my family says, things like totally
narrative. Charlie Kirk was not for saying the same things your
grandparents said. That's not what >> Like I believe white
people can experience racism.
>> Charlie Kirk was just like a commentator. He wasn't
like politically he wasn't like a politician or anything. He
was just like a guy who was on TikTok. Charlie Kirk wasn't one
of the most powerful political actors in the United States of
America before he was 30. Definitely not. Well, I think he actually
was what, like 31, 32 when he died. Hold on. How old was Charlie
Kirk? Maybe he's way older. He doesn't look that old, but maybe
he was like closer to 40. Actually, he was No, he wasn't. No,
I was about right. 32. Yeah, he's 32 when he died. So, like
conceivably before he was 30, he was one of the most powerful
conservative right-wing influences in all of American
And people are like, "This guy was just on TikTok. This guy was
just like, he was on TikTok, man." Um, I believe that uh, you
know, um, children should not have their genitals mutilated and
parents should not be allowed to chop off their kids and inject
them with hormonal therapy. You know, I mean, >> Yeah.
I just I personally think that like doing massive physical harm
to kids is wrong. And leftists, they think like cutting kids
off for no reason is so super cool. That's what leftists want
to do. That's what that's what liberals and progressives want
to do. They want to just find kids who are totally fine, totally
normal, and they want to cut their dick off. And we want to stop
that. How could you possibly hate us? We're not evil. By the
way, they want to cut their to cut their dick off so they can
them. All right. Why wouldn't you be on our side? How could you
be on their >> Kirk was a guy who represented a lot of
what I thought and what I believed. And he got assassinated.
He got shot in the [snorts] neck. And if that wasn't bad enough,
they celebrated this. The amount of liberals that I saw online
celebrating it pointing to their neck like bang bang like at
a c. >> Dude, it's so sad that this works on people. It's
like how long does it take people to figure out the tech of like
oh I found a random like Reddit comment where somebody said or
I found a random, you know, Tik Tok where before anybody saw
it before servers blew it up, it was at like 500 views and they
were celebrating Charlie died. Okay. Okay. All right. Yeah. Yeah,
you know what? That should that should definitely make you a
more staunch conservative. That should definitely change your
beliefs in some way. >> Certain point, Charlie Kurt wasn't
bad enough. Immediately after that, I Zutka's death me up just
as hard. A poor innocent white woman on the train minding her
own business got stabbed in the neck and the chest three times
while nobody did anything to help her whatsoever. And the worst
thing was is that this woman died
brutally murdered on a tram with Black Lives Matter flag put
up in her room. And the reason why she died is due to the fact
one, racism. People are trying to kill white people. They absolutely
are. And I want to quote the man who >> uh this like totally
mentally ill guy. I
he said like stupid white [__] or
>> It's so lazy and it's like so effective
and it's like to to fight against it. I feel like you have to
do so much work,
Leave it to Teone to totally blackpill me on politics and how
easy it is to just griff politics right now. Leave it to Techone
to just point out how easy it is to just say the dumbest and
have a bunch of agree with you. There was like a cho there's
a chance for humanity. Okay. I thought Hillary Clinton was the
worst. Humanity had a chance to determine whether or not it could
become like a next level civilization or if it was going to blow
itself up before it ever, you know, we we had basically could
decide whether we were past or behind the um oh the Fermy what's
the is it the Fermy filter? It's not the Fermy paradox. There's
like a filter, right? The great filter or whatever, right? There's
like a concept of every civilization, you know, because we don't
see a bunch of alien civilizations, there must be some filtering
event that you can't make it past. and we got to decide whether
we were before it or after it and whether or not we'd be filtered.
Okay? And it turns out that it was Hillary Clinton.
Americans voting for Donald Trump over Hillary Clinton. That
was the filter. And that actually proved that humanity won't
make it past like we won't become like a tier two or like a level
two level whatever civilization. We'll never actually capture
the full energy of the sun. We have determined our fate. We will
fail. We will perish. We will blow up our planet and we will
cease to exist. Okay,
that is it was Hillary. It was that election. It was that election
and that was where humanity decided we actually aren't worthy.
We can't join space fairing races. We will never make it. We're
just going to blow ourselves up. Okay, that was it. And I say
that as somebody who like hated Hillary Clinton, who thought
she was evil, who bought all of that propaganda. Okay, that was
the that was the election. Whether you could, you know, not be
fooled by somebody just lying about
and humanity is like, "No, no, no. We are actually we're too
to exist collectively. Massive sample size can't be denied. It
was over from that moment forward. >> I got that white.
And the reason why even though Zodka is dead in 2026 is due to
the fact that the court system is corrupt. It absolutely is.
Judges are seen as beall end all people, but in reality they're
just humans. And I want to remind you a judge released that black
man from prison 17 times after being a repeat offender. So, sorry
if those things offended me, but yes, that [__] was
up.
And uh I see somebody in the chat saying, "Wrift."
>> Was there ever a point where I was celebrating deaths
in my career? I I don't know. I don't know. No, no, I'll be real.
Do you want to know something that I have quote unquote grifted
on >> my viewpoints on transgenders? I'm not going to lie.
When that I started finding out about in 2012, I thought, "Okay,
this is fine." You know, let people live their life. But then
I've seen how it affects the minds of our youth. And I don't
think that it's good that Netflix is making kids question their
identity and question their with cartoon shows where >> I
I agree actually. Oh my god. Teone suddenly TTO framed it on
to Hollywood. Okay. Hollywood is trying to sigh up everybody
into becoming trans.
And really that's just one step away from figuring out who precisely
controls Hollywood. Okay. And once we start going down that rabbit
hole, Teone,
right? Why do they all want you to be trans? Why do they
all want you to be trans is the real question, isn't it?
Now I suddenly Now I suddenly get it when he puts it like that.
Now I suddenly understand. Oh my god. Thank you, Tech. >> When
I was a little kid, I thought I was Optimus Prime. I thought
I was Goku. I went into the mirror and I thought that I did the
Kamehameha.
kids are going to think crazy and we're we shouldn't be reinforcing
those ideals of well I like playing monster trucks and I'm a
girl maybe I'm a boy. I don't think we should be I'm a boy and
I like pink shirts. >> Every single person like 99.9% of
people just agree with this by the way and any belief otherwise
that like hey if if somebody's not confused and you're intentionally
trying to confuse them that's bad. Every single person believes
that, by the way. There's like a tiny tiny tiny percentage of
people who are like activists going the other direction, but
they try to represent that as a massive portion of people. It's
just not true, man. >> Mom, will you chop off my please?
I don't think that that's good for the youth to be consuming.
I just don't. And so, yeah, I've become pretty anti- against
that, but at the end of the day, I do have friends that are trans.
I'm not going to lie. I do. But they've told me their stories,
and once it's done, it's done. I just want that off the media
and I don't think we should be teaching kids about that. >> Let
me just check really quickly. Is that Asmin Gold's opinion one
to one? It Yes, I'm being told it's his father Asmin Gold's opinion
one to one. Okay, perfect. Tone and Asmin daddy on the same page.
You love to see it. Thank >> [__] And I don't
think we should be doing any of these gender surgeries until
we're at least 20. That's just me. But it's nuanced and I know
what people don't understand that. Now, moving forward. Cool.
Sorry, guys. I I had to rant a little bit here. [snorts] Oh man,
it's been a while.
>> Wow, what a rant. W rant, guys. W rant. >> Oh
man, I forgot how much I missed integration. Holy god damn. All
right, nuance equals grift. Absolutely. >> I know.
>> why 20? Uh I don't know. Probably a brain formation
thing. >> Great. Uh yeah, >> I don't know. It couldn't
possibly be different than 18. >> We're back. If you're
going to say somebody has to be an adult to get some surgery
like that, um there's no way to push it beyond 18. There's no
way you could say the other the other responsibilities you gain
at 18 would not be would not make you like perfectly if you're
if it's reasonable you have those responsibilities that you could
be drafted that you could vote and do all these different things.
Then it's totally reasonable you could chalk your dick off if
that's what you want to do. Unfortunately, the sake of a surgery.
I shouldn't even say it that way. You get surgery to make your
body align more with your mind.
Man, dude, the public eye is intoxicating. Please hold back >> I
don't know why drinking is 21 in the States. I don't get it.
But it is. >> Boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom. All right.
I I want to I want to kind of drop everything right now while
I talk about this because this shit's very serious to me. Uh
Ms. Giff and I were dating. Sorry. All right. [clears throat]
Let's uh let's get serious here. Let's get serious here for a
second.
I made a video
on Miskf.
>> Chad, we were dating. Why do you think I hate him so
much? >> And I I'll go ahead and pull it up. Let's go and
pull it up. >> Come on, man. Come on, man. >> It
was called
Miskf. And this video got
>> 700,000 views. >> No, Tech Tone, that's not just
why I hate you. I hate you because for years in Austin, you were
spreading lies about me. You were constantly telling your chat
that I did all these horrible things. You told your chat that
I'm the reason why you got kicked out of Only Things. You preparated
your chat to hating me. You were constantly saying I did horrible
things. You for nine months were constantly saying that there
was a nuke coming out about me to ruin my life and you can't
wait. You got up and
Okay, but like that nuke did come out and I do think Miz kind
of thinks it ruined his life. So, I don't know. That was probably
just like a true thing. Or maybe he just hates the fact that
Tech was celebrating it and like constantly taunting him. >> You
jerk off with your onto the camera because you acted so excited
about it. You were going around Austin telling people I shook
your girlfriend's hand too long and that I'm a weirdo. Uh you
were telling people that I am basically a in Austin, Texas and
that I'm the reason why everyone hates you.
>> Wait, right.
>> Um you also ruined Camp Canoe 2. You just went in there
and basically glazed Nick the entire time on purpose. Uh, you
basically told everyone that it sucks and that you don't want
to be there. >> Pikachu photo. >> So yeah, that's
why I hate you, Techone. I don't hate you for this one video.
I hate you for a thousand different reasons over the past two
years. >> Come on, man. Start talking about, dude, I hate
your stupid [__] face. I hate your stupid Neanderthal
[__] face. I hate your skinny shoulders that don't
fit your frame. I hate the fact that your dad and your sister
and you are all weird predators, okay? I hate everything about
you. I hate your tattoos. Your tattoos are cringe and [__]
embarrassing. Start talking about him, Miz. No, talk about the
he did to you. Talk about him. Talk about the things about him
that disgust you. Okay, let's >> I also hate you because
you're loud and annoying and I hate how you treat women and people
around you for all you are. You're a horrible human being and
the only ones that like you are the bottom fish feeders that
exist like your buddy or your other friend
>> three months ago.
And in this video,
I thought I was
>> great idea.
>> Oh, he's going to put the pink photo. >> I would
like to say in this video >> in the slightest. >> Pretty
fair. >> I do. >> Now, if you guys don't know who
this is, this is um, Pinku. This is Tech's ex who filed the protective
order against him. Just for context, if you guys don't know who
Pinku is, this helpful video, show you who Pinku is. Okay,
>> very helpful, very educational. your
>> and I just got them to ask because I never knew why
Miz just started to not like me so much.
>> Um I got
>> Okay. All right. Okay. I don't get it. I probably needed
the context from earlier in the stream. I'm guessing >> what
if the doctor is an undercover spy for techone retaliation for
the court
The reason why I didn't like Techone is because I thought he
was going to steal Emmy from me and I didn't want that to >> I
guess I'm going to ask him this.
>> And he said this quote >> cuz he's so handsome.
>> That was like a Batman super villain quote, which is
>> Let's go quote for quote, Teone. Let's do it. Let's
go. Quote for quote. I'm
>> Let me see.
>> Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Critical Rad, thank you for
the primer. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you. >> This one
from a 16-year-old child, which is, I've given you advice that
is 100% proven, factually correct multiple times. You never take
it. I've given you thou I've given thousands of people factual
advice that aids them. They take it and they're happy.
uh Net Sky, thank you for the five gifted over on Twitch. Let's
go W. Thank you very much, Net Sky. Appreciate it, >> What
do you got for your quote, Techone? >> Let's go day.
If you don't know who the bottom of the totem pole is,
that's because you're the bottom of the totem pole.
And when I heard that, >> does that mean I'm the most supportive
>> I just realized,
oh Jesus,
>> wait, when he heard what? >> I've given you thou
I've given thousands of people factual advice.
>> These are probably DMs he sent to the sister. I'm not
up on this yet. We'll we'll check this out as it comes out. >> They
take it and they're happy. What do you got for me? What's your
quote, Techone? What's your quote of the day?
>> If you don't know who the bottom of the totem pole,
>> right, he's talking out to Techone, maybe. I see. I
see. >> That's because you're the bottom of the totem pole.
>> I got it. >> And when I heard that, does that
mean I'm the most supportive person?
I just realized,
oh Jesus,
there is literally
nothing coming back from that. And this is kind of like, you
know, Rich used to be the bottom of the totem bowl in OTK. Everybody
remembered when Rich was in OTK. He was the butt of the joke
for everything.
And then when Rich got removed and then Miz had his controversy,
Miz became the butt of the joke for a while and he couldn't handle
that. So then he kind of had to force all of the butt of the
joke to being >> I'm sorry. There was never a point in
OTK history where Rich was the butt of the joke and Teto wasn't.
Rich is like a super cool, super charismatic, super handsome
dude with a massive. Okay, Rich was never the butt of the joke.
If I remember correctly, Rich, you could say Rich was the butt
of the joke, but when he was actually hanging out with OTK, and
correct me if I'm wrong, because I'm not an OTK lore master.
I hate to reference this guys like that. But I'm pretty sure
it was like Elinity and Mia Khalifa or Oh, sorry, what's her
name? Not Mia Khalifa. I'm thinking of Mia Khalifa, but um Mia
Malova. They were like fighting over Rich, right? Didn't Rich
have like a whole bunch of those people, bro? That guy was like
cool as
that that guy was cool as the whole time? I don't know who the
[__] you're talking about when you say Rich is like
the joke. Rich was never the joke. Okay.
and I had a full psych evaluation.
Um, I'm doing a followup
uh every two weeks uh for a couple however long they think they
need me. Um,
and I guess >> he's just walking it back now that it's
obvious he never got a diagnosis. Well, he's walking it back
now. Yaposaurus Rex. Sorry, I'll I'll pull that up on stream.
He's walking it back now because now it will affect his life.
Now he's put it on the record. It will start affecting his life.
And so what he has to do is start, oh well actually I was just
going to get treatment and they told me like actually maybe you
don't have schizophrenia. It's a miracle guys. It's like realistically
he probably only used this excuse when something bad was happening
in his life. It's been his go-to excuse for a long time. Oh,
I couldn't sleep cuz I'm schizophrenic. Oh, I Oh yeah, I did
almost [__] that up. Well, it's cuz I I like saw
something right. And now out of nowhere suddenly we're like cured.
we we don't have it anymore because now it would affect you know
this protect I believe it affected the protective order significantly
that that testimony affected the protective order significantly.
Okay. Um I'm not
>> I went in with my dad. I kind of said hey sometimes
I see things that aren't >> Um and they said you're schizophrenic.
They gave me medicine. I took those medicines. They made me a
zombie. Um I went to a psychiatrist yesterday and uh I'll I'll
try to provide some documentation for this at a later date when
I receive it. Uh guys, I'm not
Uh the psychiatrist believes the reason why I see things that
aren't there mainly well at night uh is due to the fact that
I got stabbed in my left eye and my right eye is normal. And
so they believe that my eyeballs are causing me to temporarily
hallucinate things that aren't there because they're not they're
not signaling my brain properly. and what they believe. >> Now,
now I think
that sounds reasonable,
but like hold on. Am I crazy?
Do you guys not have this at all? Do you guys not ever have the
thing where you're like doing stuff at night where you're like
slightly falling asleep and you like see something there and
it freaks you out for a millisecond and you realize you're just
seeing things, right? Has nobody else had this? Am I
No, he doesn't hear voices. He has visual hallucinations. I don't
I say he hears voices cuz it's a joke, right? >> Addressing
the elephant in the room.
Uh I lost the civil case. >> I did.
>> he lost the civil case. >> Um did it go the way
I wanted is what it is. But I do genuinely want to respect the
court's decision. Uh, at this point
I'm not sure
what route I want to take from here, but I believe even though
I lost the case, I do believe that
this still gets me to where I want to go, which is for all parties
to simply move >> I think I unless somebody can show me
evidence to the contrary, I feel like she moved on quite a while
ago,
And I think she only went back to file the protective order case
because you weren't moving on. If you had moved on, things would
have been fine. I understand. So, so I'm not saying they both
moved on immediately. Okay? Because Pink was obviously upset
about this assault, about how the relationship went. She was
obviously upset after, right? Justifiably so.
So, she wasn't necessarily moving on. I don't know if I I wouldn't
argue she has to move on if she feels like she was violated,
right? if she was violated. I say if she feels if she was violated,
right, she doesn't have to move on. She can pursue that however
she likes
and then eventually she realized like, oh, I'm not going to get
what I want out of this. I'm not going to like probably it might
be difficult to actually seek justice through the criminal system.
I'm not totally sure. We'll see. But she eventually decided like,
I'm going to suspend this cuz I just I don't want to do anymore.
And then after that, you kept talking. You kept yapping about
her and then she filed the protective order. She filed for a
protective order.
I don't know. It seems like pretty obvious. I will say if he
just is going to leave her alone completely, not comment on her,
leave her alone. It seems like everybody got what they want.
You got there in the end. You pay her court fees. It sucks you
both had to go through this, but everybody can move on. I personally
believe
that his story around this stuff is very suspicious. I feel like
there probably was some kind of course of control going on in
the relationship, but I I don't know for sure. And I I believe
her when she says she was assaulted. I think that seems like
probably they're playing it close to the line. Probably there
was not clear communication.
I think she has every right to pursue that. I don't know how
it'll go. And
yeah, I don't know what else to say.
I I'm you know, I don't want to poo poo her. I just Yeah, it
basically if I feel like it's not going to go the way she wants,
I should probably just shut the [__] up. I think
you know what I mean.
>> The system has failed me. Yes.
And I do believe in an America where consent cannot be retracted
one year later.
However,
>> there's no evidence that that's what happened.
There's no evidence that she consented.
She's never said that. There's no statement leading that direction.
Right.
At the end of the day, uh, I want to move forward with my life
and so I am going to admit that I [__] up. >> I
should not have tweeted that much.
Straight up.
>> So gay. I should not have tweeted that much. That is
not why you were found liable for Sorry. That's not why they
found a reasonable likelihood. They they found it reasonably
likely that you committed sexual assault. What is the wording?
I should just go to the wording. I should literally like put
a sticky note here so I can just say the wording of the court
cuz I I ain't catching that smoke, dog. Not me. That's not my
life. They found reasonable grounds to believe that you assaulted
They found reasonable grounds to believe that you assaulted Pink.
That's what I'm going to say. Um, does this kind of really not
eventually become a violation? What are you talking about, evil
Johnny Bravo? I don't know what you're talking about here. Anyway,
we uh Let me pull the video back up. We got to keep going.
>> Uh, I want to move forward with my life and so I am
going to admit that I up. I should not have tweeted that much.
Straight up. I think I should not have tweeted that much. I was
tweeting like crazy. I hope people can understand why I was tweeting
that much. But at the end of the day, I should have practiced
self-control.
I got out of hand. This consumed my brain and it sucked the things
I was being called. So, I tweeted a lot. Uh, going forward, uh,
I'm just like not going to tweet. U, like barely at all. Uh,
I un
it's really the tweeting stuff is bad for the stalking thing.
It is not bad for the assault thing like that. It doesn't affect
the sexual assault thing, right?
Those are two different things that you were found that they
found reasonable likelihood of, right?
Do I have to pull the tweet one more time? Reasonable grounds.
There is reasonable grounds to believe that you did assault and
you were stalking.
Yes. Yes.
So again, the stalking thing, you probably yourself tweeting.
I would say the assault thing that the probable cause was probably
the surgeon testifying or whatever. The plastic surgeon testifying
and you backing up the fact that you would up somebody's lip
fillers fillers right around that time. That's probably enough
for their their probable cause. I have found such
calmness,
such beautiful
>> such a beautiful life I found since taking all this
time off. And I and I kind of found
>> the man who I want to be and the life that I want to
live
>> and I have found the person who I want to live with.
[snorts] Uh, so I will say I got engaged
uh
about
three months ago.
so that's what he's announcing. Guys, the final final announcement
on my stream addressing my assault allegations and my stalking
allegations is I got
I just want to kick off the pool, the dead pool for my my wife
to be in style. Okay, how long until this woman no longer exists
on this earth? Guys, let the let the bets start now.
I'm trying to do a drum roll, but if I do a drum roll only without
my voice talking, you guys can't hear it. So, I have to like
do sounds in the meantime. I have to like talk while I do it
or you don't hear it at all.
Third victim
coming soon. Third victim. Wait, you can hear if I just do it.
Oh, no. It doesn't all come through. It comes through a little
bit. >> You'll never guess with who.
Uh
but I it'll probably become painfully obvious over the uh
next couple months, years, but uh life is going in a very very
good direction. And I'm very grateful to have uh such a beautiful
person in my life. >> Who is it? It's his girlfriend Sophia.
He's been dating for a while. >> Is you know there for
me when I really needed it. Um
I got engaged to Shina.
[laughter] Anyways, anyways, anyways, anyways. Uh I'm not going
to >> I'm too
anybody with that. But uh life is very good right now. Um we're
going to get back to the things. Um, I'm sure that you guys will
probably hear even worse things over the next 24 hours, 48 hours.
But at the end of the day, if anybody ever cut ties with me,
publicly or privately, that's okay, guys. It It really is. Save
your own skin. Do your own thing. I understand. There's a certain
cloud uh that follows me. Yeah. >> Yeah, of course. Mega,
come here. Come >> I was watching. >> You were watching.
[laughter]
>> Me and Marissa were both watching. >> Yeah. Was
it a good stream?
>> Yeah. I >> I was curious if you were going to
say >> Yeah. No, I I I love this woman more than anything.
>> Yeah, but uh it's it's going to be very obvious. And
uh >> Yeah, I thought I'd just come up.
>> that's crazy. I
I h how do I put it?
I listen just like there are Captain Sabos out there, people
who are like, I can fix her. She's just like, I can fix him.
I got it. I got this. I got this. I got this,